[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora il tempo ciao vi saluto e
comincio subito contatto questo
contratto che è una parola che ha
tantissimi significati si in generale ma
soprattutto diversi quasi
personali per ognuno perché il concetto
così intimo e ampio anche che lo
comprendiamo davvero
solo attraverso la nostra esperienza che
abbiamo vissuto anche se osservata ma
comunque durante il corso della nostra
vita quindi è stato tutto difficile
all'inizio non sapevo come immettermi
del disco per senza tv che cosa
condividere e ho fatto questa cosa un po
così tornata su dizionario che sono da
vedermi le definizioni provare un
proprio parole non lo so qualcosa
e stato divertente perché la primissima
definizione di contatto su tutti i
dizionari dal latino con tingere vuol
dire toccare
toccare che cade perfettamente a fagiolo
sulla mia esperienza primaria con il
contatto con il mondo esterno le persone
ma anche me stessa soprattutto che è
quello che la musica la musica e suono
che ne nasce attraverso il tocco
letteralmente proprio anche il
linguaggio tecnico nel mio strumento che
il pianoforte stesso mi siedo subito è
chiarissimo perché letteralmente sola
nasce dal mio contatto tevere azione dal
mio corpo e quello dello strumento
quindi il mio peso di un abbraccio le
mani le dita al patto dal tasto proprio
del pianoforte se io faccio questo
nasce il suono da questa straordinaria è
che questo sono entrerà in contatto con
voi
c'è la consapevolezza né il peso della
differenza di questo suono
che vi arriverà in modo diverso a voi
che a me
rispetto a come nasce come muore
e così diventa un filo
diventa
un portale
e riesce a commettere me e voi senza che
ci conosciamo senza che ci parliamo e
senza che ci tocchiamo nemmeno questa
magia straordinaria succede anche
soltanto attraverso il suono quindi una
nota semplicissima o anche un rumore una
qualsiasi onda sonora che entra in
contatto con voi ma diventa fortissima
quando cominciamo a parlare di musica
perché dentro la musica ci riconosciamo
la musica che non è altro che una serie
di relazioni tra suoni che creano
armonia
armonia che
occupano spazio
ci rende parte di qualcosa ci prepara ad
entrare
questo spazio a questo tempo in questa
situazione
poi c'è la melodia
che ci parlano e poi c'è il ritmo e il
polso che lo fa altro che sincronizzarsi
tutti insieme e questo è bellissimo la
tra lo strato in aria infatti il piccolo
fan fact cosa siamo ad un concerto
ascoltiamo tutti la stessa cosa nello
stesso posto lo stesso momento il nostro
cuore batte tutti questa cosa la prima
volta che ho scoperto stavo per piangere
e quindi nulla nella musica che tutta
questa serie di informazioni piccole ma
anche macro informazioni in realtà ci
arrivano addosso con una freccia
unificate con un 1 noi non sentiamo
tante cose sentiamo una sola e questo
uno qui tocca la nostra coscienza
e quindi le nostre corde la stessa cosa
che abbiamo tutti nello stesso modo ma è
diverso per tutti perché lo passiamo lo
filtriamo attraverso il nostro vissuto
questa cosa altra cosa incredibile che
spiega molto facilmente il motivo per il
quale cose diverse si commuovono
sentiamo così diverse ascoltando la
stessa cosa però siamo tutti nello
stesso stato
siamo tutti nello stesso stato e per far
sì che questa cosa succeda per far sì
che la nostra coscienza si muove quindi
che ci sia lo spazio per emozionarci ci
sono una serie di cose che dobbiamo
tenere in considerazione
di cui adesso non vi sto a spiegare
perché è lunga
tutta una serie di intervalli di
rapporti matematici anche di numeri
attraverso le quinte gli armonici
insomma cosa è
così che accadono nel momento in cui chi
suona riesce ad azzerare il proprio ego
è veramente ad annullare il proprio ego
che non vuol dire cancellare il
contratto con noi stessi e quindi
servire gli altri
ma vuol dire servire la musica per far
desistere quanto quello che è ovvero un
portale e nel momento in cui la musica
diventa portale le cose riescono a
succedere quindi io mi emoziona voi vi
emozionato quando non lo facciamo stiamo
procedendo in un altro modo che non è
sbagliato ma non ci mette in contatto ci
presenta quindi utilizziamo la musica
per presentare un'idea che noi abbiamo
river e stessi non è più un filo più un
tubo è uno schermo
e
nella musica classica questa cosa molto
difficile
perché bisogna tenere conto di tante
cose appunto quelle di cui vi accennavo
un altro né questo è la mia vita anche
studiando la un pochino la musica
classica mi sono resa conto che c'è un
modo
semplice per far accadere la stessa cosa
e questo modo è usare la voce
la voce che è una cosa che è di tutti ea
due poteri
principali fortissimi tipo un supereroe
che ne fa poi nascere una che è
incredibile la voce direzionale
e ha il potere della parola è l'unico
strumento in natura quindi non costruito
che ha il potere della parola della
lingua di esplicitare il messaggio di
rendere esplicito quello che io voglio
dire e ti dà la possibilità di dirlo a
qualcuno
se io faccio questo adesso
[Musica]
a chi lo suonato
lo suonato un po per tutti
però se faccio non so
se faccio
tu sai che ho cantato a te
mentre non l'ho cantato a te se faccio
tu sai che lo ha cacciato the ok ci
vediamo il più pagato del secondo me è
potentissima e da questo fatto qui nasce
la possibilità che ha la voce di cantare
la melodia
la melodia che il nostro ricordo la
melodia che diventa il nostro riporta
esempio in una canzone
davvero dire che quella cosa che ci
ricordiamo è quella cosa che impariamo
che sappiamo come fa se io mi faccio
volare poi mi fate
cantare
ma anche se mi faccio la la la la
[Musica]
la la
o se facessi
[Musica]
e che cosa è successo è successo che noi
siamo tutti nello stesso ricordo in
questo momento noi siamo tutti nello
stesso posto nello stesso momento con lo
stesso ricordo come se condividessimo
tutti quanti un esatto momento in cui ci
ricordiamo come se adesso io vi
chiedessi ma vi ricordate di quella
volta in cui e voi tutti dice sì certo
si è questa cosa succede nel momento in
cui conosciamo la melodia sempre con
tutti è veramente il modo più inclusivo
di sempre di condividere qualcosa
e questo è il motivo esatto per il quale
noi abbiamo bisogno della musica è il
motivo per il quale noi la amiamo così
tanto e per il quale la sentiamo così
vicina rispetto forse magari ad altre
cose
perché non siamo soli siamo tutti nello
stesso ricordo ma noi siamo insieme e
cantiamo il nostro cuore batte
all'unisono
e questa cosa trovo incredibile non
trovo veramente straordinario e nulla mi
piaceva condividere con voi questo
questo fatto qui il fatto che con la
musica non siamo soli
[Applauso]